not the onuses on women it's like we're  responsible for the men that we pick  yeah yeah I agree with that part but she  was saying how um she thinks that guys  are like the shy guys they don't have  the common approachment because  partially but it's partially our fault  because feminism had this whole me too  move here yeah so and so like we're  complaining like they're shy because  they don't know if they're going to be  me too if they approach the wrong girl  no no seriously there's there's  a YouTuber that just came out where he  he approached a girl in public and she  literally called the the Park police on  him and this was in 2022. yeah